hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba this
is Lauren Francesca Lauren is the only
guest where I say her name for her
because she is that important
follow her on I want my Lauren on
YouTube immediately she's everything
about social media as I want my lord but
YouTube's that may want to follow her on
hey Lauren what's up do you have the
hodgetwins are of course see that is the
most common answer for the hodgetwins I
have never seen a hodgetwins video I
don't know who these guys are for like a
couple years now people been saying
tubular hard Tunes compilation never
have done it for some reason and then
there was one guy who's really harping
on my ass about you gotta check out a
hodgetwins to it I've been asking
forever never done it's been like a year
man and so you know one thing does
recommend is to turn into a try not to
laugh challenge supposedly these guys
are really funny
are you ready Lauren I'm ready try not
to laugh don't laugh okay anything I
know about you you don't have a sense of
humor stacks a teeth tip won't don't
come over this cool it ain't about ten
miles away we can hang out and be
buddies again okay don't do it man we
could converse along there keeps a
little with a boom back and I'm bashing
the [ __ ] up somebody killing themselves
just a process we feel good
a small world man goddamn [ __ ] kind of
scary though people but I'm ok you can
be dangerous too if you don't plan right
you put on YouTube talking [ __ ] about
everybody I might come up and sneak up
in it man so goddamn skull in hey she
saw a pitcher Percy vigilant to that day
knowledge you got damn [ __ ] my only e
Cleve it's gonna just cleavers I just
got one of snapchat cups going blonde
hair blue eyes yeah I spoke with Tobias
hey this was an announcement we've got
some pretty I to you yeah we come into
Chicago okay
you got some pretty eyes nice here thank
you we've come to Chicago Illinois June
29th you know what a great day today you
know what she really means right what
she needs to suck you off on the grill
chair she got pretty I like that a date
with my girl stayed y'all got some
pretty eyes which she really was saying
this I want to suck both of y'all's hey
Chris how the [ __ ] it is fake was not
fake
just to the bottom Sears fish right here
right okay why does that look like that
if I'd known the Sun is directly above
my name of 119 retain high and I've got
damn high no matter how new is 118 cut
this [ __ ] off and you know get the
[ __ ] wait a minute
oh [ __ ] look in the [ __ ] echo some
not so I get it [ __ ] right now so she's
probably killing two dudes Bram and
Dixon in each other you know let it sit
she's probably playing like that playing
with herself you have to do zealots Oh
Oh take your knife oh just like oh yeah
put the - ah ha I rely world and I twins
parties [ __ ] good indeed [ __ ] out of
here go across treatment time yeah
surprise yeah go across street but we
can s be two gay guys [ __ ] old man
right shut up that's love right down I
smell smoke
lucky just got done plowing it what do
you know porky I get a big of that you
definitely did [ __ ] together you
won't kill people for ITT robbery today
I never make it about her or even call
it a dyke just trying to ease her into a
lifestyle change
I'm really not there leave out too long
man how long it god damn damn just cut
the land progress Minh does it go go to
the gut their notebooks talking with him
that their BBC's will spikes on internet
[ __ ] so when she brands that [ __ ] in
your head it just rips your Apple no I
don't do that because you might like it
me like you know what I want the real
thing
you're going a [ __ ] to come in here I'm
open in my ass
oh okay [ __ ] oh god damn is [ __ ]
meal Oh a minute meal oh we just fix
mine wait a minute [ __ ] you don't break
my [ __ ] I can put a cool I'll thrown
all over my skin I could fill it blowing
all over these games step-free on next
oh and what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
man yeah three tilt it forward [ __ ]
guessing to that goes makes me look like
I got some Beetlejuice action yeah you
can take it I like Sheldon Beetlejuice
action going there you go thank you boo
[ __ ] [ __ ] on my coat and he or she
married I'm an open because I helped to
put in a placement and and we could [ __ ]
I'm shooting a video
hello when is Singapore pay after the
face yo YouTube oh hang a bit of face my
crazy party tonight I love them I'm not
gonna leave him nothing underneath maybe
she didn't let botch it should have been
available to another girl to have
another few but started getting [ __ ]
his ass
older what do they call that bisexual
[ __ ] the [ __ ] you mean what they call
it they call that Bob sexual orgies okay
she started I got there comes back with
gone man
he's gone god damn son [ __ ] he nothing
wrong with chunky chunky feels good -
yeah but when you get to that job up
level what's so funny going back to that
at the end of Jabba the Hutt love you
Nick and pourcel is warm you could
[ __ ] kill somebody with this
committee oh she asked if it is he wants
this was that when he come together
Conan that's all cultural my god
danyoung the seminal book we got back
together has been up up until a week ago
the girl that he cheated on her will
cannot get his wife Oh get the [ __ ] out
marry off because she's cheating
honeymoons right yeah see
ah miss bastard
what is that waiting down look summer
hey there's nothing [ __ ] for space
doesn't horseback sum it over what you
know what's that odor I got the shape
will I ain't forget I said [ __ ] you
it lays long
we're really happening without pounding
the wife right-handed nothing out and I
was all sweaty I in collection we got to
talk about what [ __ ] kind of job you
got now that's all that's all you gonna
get man I know what you do know you can
make just [ __ ] up
I've got that thing I want to say well
let me say [ __ ] is what else up you know
what you do maybe you going to point it
and that's why I want you talking so
goodbye Julie 16 minutes just like only
one show you Tamara China may God talk
to you man give me Caroline go to home
twist to it give me part time
[ __ ] yeah for when it don't
succeed which you think will Brooks my
[ __ ] bitching that's less it 18 tuna
[ __ ] it's not you been eating [ __ ] I
paint girls so but I got up in them you
know sighs make it to [ __ ] off me yeah
you [ __ ] crushing my insides so I
kill dick it's in my stomach I don't
like that [ __ ] yeah I said well you know
what I don't like [ __ ] you either get
the [ __ ] out of my house like that
that's the problem man well much brother
doesn't really milk hi Jason
chicken hi I'm chef Anki this time it's
going Kia's like I say is a [ __ ] from
Fort Wayne in there yeah you gotta be
black bless he's a [ __ ] father
that sounds like a black person I'm just
going by [ __ ] statistic other laughes
of the white dude these surfers you're
like damn post Malone or some [ __ ] all
right
being single person I will see this
[ __ ] anyway only if you female
you can sin [ __ ] it'll be send me
they'll get their mail [ __ ] smiling
[ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] I wanna see that
[ __ ] cool cool Rochester tacos and I
thought take three of the Cool Ranch
Tacos with no socks no man free nacho
and three Cool Ranch 10 free nacho and
one handed you just said ready tacos my
OD gentlemen oh you told him that not
bad my friends thanks to the boy I was
dating for the past year I've become a
big fan of you guys in your videos she
said boy yeah time I said thank you
first of all y'all gonna want to send us
a big [ __ ] you to him because his
birthday present for me was supposed to
be tickets to your upcoming show in
Toronto Canada but he decided he didn't
want to go I'm gonna take that thank you
backing up [ __ ] you [ __ ]
they get your [ __ ] out my ear I am
impressed
yeah the sound turned on every line
number theory
no workers to tow goddamn my throat
[ __ ] Savage I'm just contrived cousin
cut
so this wait just once the attic taste
with the bag of [ __ ] so if you're
watching you know who you are mr. oh you
use enough to get to that [ __ ]
yeah she's trying to get back to that
more folksy using up his toys hmm shut
up you can consider moving the chickadee
drunk over there Hey Wow
dude I'm so hungry right now what would
look so delicious you're here started
you eat before coming no but I just grab
before you showed up Lauren I know but
now like I haven't what the [ __ ] why
would you girl
what the [ __ ] wrong with you what's
wrong with your way some of the language
is I thought they were like family
friendly that was far from family
friendly man yeah a lot of gay jokes a
lot of [ __ ] jokes
yeah raunchy a lot of incredibly raunchy
kinda thought they were really funny
yeah as a few tiser I was really I'm
like clenched my teeth to get her to not
laugh it's really funny to see twins
like I get along so incredibly well with
each other because as much as like
banter they have they make each other
crack up like all the time they just
seem so comfortable with each other he's
going to really love each other I mean
there is so much voter talk in there I
have to ask this question out loud how
many three so do you think they've been
involved with the same girl I don't know
I don't know 12 thank ya I think 12 is
the right number I feel like once they
reach 12 they destroy that awkward you
know what I totally think it would be
surprisingly there's so many people have
heard of that her brothers that do that
have you and your brother just ah I
don't even want to know he has a penis
the same way I don't want to know that
girl's fart please that same feeling
[Laughter]
all right why did you bring this up
because you brought that that's our
fault the hot shrink of funny guys
they're really funny I'm glad this was
my introduction to him because I had no
idea they were before
what are their like blogs or something
yeah baby comedy shows they said they're
performing yeah I guess I don't know I
always thought that they may because
like I've been noticed some years ago
like they look a little bit old another
married so yeah I've no idea
we got watch some Moree another
hysterical bad as shocking stuff they
were staged a little too many like gay
jokes for me but there were some gay
jokes like now you're like the gay ones
but I mean they're like gay talks you
get a lot of pictures from meals I get I
get way more photos from God that I've
ever gotten from any girls usually black
guys - yeah it's usually black eyes
would like NASA dicks where I'm like I
wouldn't even have to do that if I was
gay okay I want to know what to do okay
look see that and I clench like I feel
the pain it's like when you're scared of
heightened look off a rooftop and you're
being almost like what my you know thank
you
what my think my mum yeah okay you know
I'm applying all right well thanks for
sending that are away all you guys
that's a little more challenging try not
to lock down as I've ever done man kind
of pretty county executive subscribe to
the rail rejects click that notification
bell I want my Lauren on YouTube follow
her and mediate movie we have a patreon
and it does something just go to patreon
is a good website I just like the site
or check out other people you don't even
you check us out